(laughter)
- What is this?
(electronic music)
- We have a saying in French.
Cheese that does not smell
can not be an honest cheese.
- We like to eat cheese
with wine, and just,
we eat it for the cheese,
whereas here, cheese
you eat it with something else.
- Yea with crackers or in
France you just eat cheese,
just a piece of cheese like this.
- And not with crackers.
- Yea, nothing.
- Not necessarily looking
forward to trying this but,
- Let's see!
(jazzy instrumental music)
- It's just one color.
- Yea.
- It's just, there's no
like little things in it.
- No spice or nothing.
- Nothing.
- It's very simple.
(jazzy instrumental music)
- It's not bad but it's
what we call in France
the cheese for kid.
- It tastes like cheese for one
second and then it does not.
- It has a bit of bitterness
to it but very, very light.
- Doesn't it feel a bit smoked?
- Tastes milky.
- It tastes like the
cream you put in coffee,
like half and half.
(jazzy instrumental music)
- Oh my. This looks like mayo.
- The texture is very sandy and dry.
- How does it taste?
- I taste like those little
cheese puff that you can buy.
- Mayonnaise cheese sauce with a bit
of light orange coloring.
- It's like a mixture
between salty and sweet
but at the same time it's
neither and really acidic.
- You're in a rush to get your food,
you're going to get food that tastes
like it has been made in a rush.
And it doesn't have to taste bad
but won't taste as good as it could be.
- You should eat food
because you enjoy it,
you enjoy the taste of it,
you shouldn't just eat it
to fill yourself up.
- Yea.
- And a lot of this
American cheese in general
feels just like to fill yourself up
or to put on a burger
and just kind of eat it.
- And it doesn't taste, it doesn't taste.
- It doesn't taste like anything.
- So it's not good for your body
and it isn't good for your
desire to eat something good.
- Yea.
(upbeat instrumental music)